أجنبي
[موسيقى]
محظوظ جدًا لوجود روابط مهمة
وتاريخية مع أصدقائنا
وحلفائنا بين دول الخليج ،
ونتطلع إلى الأمام ما نريده هو
علاقة حديثة مبنية ليس
فقط على تعاوننا الدفاعي والأمني ​​التاريخي
ولكن أيضًا
تعزز  الحوار الاقتصادي والشراكة
والتنمية ودول مجلس التعاون الخليجي اتفاقية التجارة
الحرة هي جزء كبير من ذلك وأنا
أتطلع إلى خططنا
للتقدم في أوائل العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
مارس أن إيران لم تنتهز
الفرصة ل  المضي قدمًا
وأعتقد أن الوضع الآن
صعب للغاية وسيتعين علينا التفكير
في أفضل الخطوات التالية مع
شركائنا الدوليين ولكن هذا الأمر أصبح
أكثر صعوبة بسبب معاملة إيران العنيفة
للمتظاهرين
وأفعالهم المستمرة التي تزعزع
استقرار  الحكومة الإقليمية
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] ستقرر أفضل السبل
للإجابة الآن من الواضح أن الحل
السلمي هو الأفضل ولكنك تعلم
لست متأكدًا من أنه من العدل أن نطلب من
الأوكرانيين القدوم إلى طاولة المفاوضات
في نفس الوقت
الذي تتعرض فيه بلادهم للهجوم العنيف
[موسيقى] أجنبية